simplifier la façon d'encadrer et
d'afficher ses photos sur un mur c'est
défi que se sont lancé deux designers
montréalais une fascination incroyants
avec la photographier plus que jamais
elle parce que tout le monde un appareil
de haute qualité dans leurs proches dans
leur téléphone cellulaire par les
réseaux sociaux facebook des choses
comme ça de mettre une photo ou moules
pour juste l'avoir dans notre
environnement sap a changé quand besoin
d'un plus on encore besoin d'un
processus
un peu compliqué pour arriver à voir une
photo qu'on venait avec le concept flexi
plus besoin de clous de crochets ou
d'outils et poser un cadre prend moins
d'une minute
l'idée de flexi c'est vraiment de
simplifier le processus de la pose d'un
cadre énormément la première chose qu'on
fait avec 1,4 c comptant au moins pour
avoir une idée ou est-ce qu'on veut le
mettre
et c'est à partir de l'ocs la galère
commence on a besoin d'utiliser un cloud
explique ci est composée d'un système
d'ancrage sur lequel sont intégrés un
adhésif et un niveau l'élément cental
c'est vraiment cette cette composante
loti qui remplace le clou et le crochet
l'innovation repose aussi sur ses quatre
petites pattes à ressorts grâce auquel
on peut glisser le cadre sur le mur pour
trouver la position idéale
les premières versions qu'on avait fait
il n'est pas ça et c'est très frustrant
d'arriver tavel adhésif tu mets ton mari
ça collait au mauvais endroit
donc c'est là que l'idée du partage
une fois le cadre bien placé suffit de
presser pour le coller ce qu'on a à
faire c'est la photo placée en moi si je
veux changer l'orientation le pousseur
ce changement nous soyons ont retiré le
cadre suffit de tirer sur la langue est
une idée toute simple sur laquelle les
designers travaillent depuis quelques
mois
y'a du prototypage ça commence en carton
ça commence avec des dessins ça commence
avec toutes sortes de méthodes
traditionnelles et éventuellement on
arrive à des quotas les technologies
d'aujourd'hui le cadre coûte entre 15 et
20 dollars fixi demeure un prototype
avant de le rendre disponible ces
créateurs doivent réunir le financement
nécessaire pour lancer la production qui
sera entièrement faite localement ici
vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal